now at the peak of it the smugglers are
bringing in like 3040 thousand dollars
at the time
one woman smuggler she was stopped in
Phoenix Sky Harbor Airport and they were
in vitamin containers jars in her
luggage they took her in a room empty
the luggage out searched through it put
the pills on the table he said - what
are they shed vitamins and they were
like cool put them back in the luggage
and sold - have a nice day so after that
after that I consulted a lawyer and the
lawyer said stop bringing them in to
America bring him in through Mexico so I
invested in a beachfront condo in pods
Penasco Rocky Point where the students
from Arizona and California they go down
there and they party there's a lot of
people coming and going during certain
times of the year to bring loads over
the border the Arizona border and my
smugglers would fly from Hermosillo
Airport over to Mexico City they'd get
her friends over to Paris and then
they'd jump on a train you know through
over to Holland so jumping on a on a
plane from Holland back to the States
you're gonna get busted very easily
doing now and this was before 9/11 so
nobody please try this now you know you
could you could when you run your actual
flight back to Mexico you could have
people literally sometimes had the pills
just in pillowcases in their luggage if
you want it to be more secure you could
have them screwed into computer towers
and bring computer towers back instead
and then once they got to Hermosillo the
pills would be transferred when they
were smuggled back down to Rocky Point
over to other people in case the
original
smugglers have been detected in any way
and the secondary group of people will
be down there in like nice SUVs with ASU
University of Arizona Arizona State
University stickers on them diving tanks
tourists bric-a-brac
you know when you got to the border and
I was like I said I was illegal alien
but I was confident enough to just go
down to Mexico then because they didn't
ask you for ID they just asked if you
were a US citizen and if you white and
you just get through basically so that's
what happened I smuggled numerous people
in from England who had been deported
Wildman could be point free time so
being a menace to society I just have
people smuggling him back in through
Mexico so it was quite easy for us to
cross the border and nobody ever got
busted
bringing pills across the Arizona border
in from Mexico Wow now how how did you
get involved with the is it called the
New Mexican Mafia yeah how did you get
involved with the New Mexican Mafia and
for those who don't know who what is the
New Mexican Mafia okay there's a movie
called American me American me about la
ma so these are gangs that come out of
the prison system and you know you've
heard of the Aryan Brotherhood that came
out of the California prison system a
lot of these gangs originated in the
California prison system and it spreads
throughout the country okay so you know
there's a California la ma and then they
branched out and there was a Arizona let
ma and these are Chicanos Mexican
Americans not like the original Mexican
Mafia like the cartels out of Mexico and
some people do confuse that okay now now
I mentioned the wild man was opening the
door to a lot of relationships with
gangsters because he's just so loud and
wherever he goes he attracts this
eclectic group of people in these
apartments he's got like transvestite
Native Americans in one corner Russian
mafia over here
Chicano gang members over here
gangbangers over here
street prostitutes it's just this
eclectic makes people everyone's on
to see and everyone's getting along and
telling some of the life stories and
[ __ ] it's crazy so anyway we were at an
apartment party in a complex in Tempe
called Rancho Murieta this was a huge
complex so we had multiple apartments in
there where we could party out where we
could store ecstasy where we could do
deals out of etc and we were in one of
those apartments and everyone was just
chilly now people smoking weed listening
to rave music people Aleksey having a
good time I'm there to supply the
ecstasy and this Mexican American guy
comes in and he's supplying the weed and
the coke and Kazmir the supply as we hit
it off and we start talking so a
policeman walks in a tempe policeman and
he goes I could smell weed from outside
nobody move and the guy I'm speaking to
just pours out gum points at the cop
goes the only one who's not leaving is
you [ __ ] everybody run so we all
run off into the night now I've never
seen anything this heavy before so I'm
crapping myself I go to one of the
nearest apartments where we've got
people in the selling pills for us and
we're hearing the sirens we're in a
helicopter come in and we're all like
[ __ ] what we're going to do should we
flush our pills or what we're gonna get
busted but there was also like so many
people at that apartment party were
hoping that the cop kinda would
recognize us maybe if we got rounded up
so while we're debating whether to flush
our stuff
all of a sudden French window Batman Man
Man Man Man Batman is in the cops
[Laughter]